hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
congratulations to daniel mai 13 years
old for winning the 2019 raytheon math
counts national competition
the prize includes a 20 000 college
scholarship
the final round was a speed test
competition between mai and tsuyash
pandit
it was pencil and paper only no
calculators were allowed
here's the question that sealed the
victory
what is the quotient of 5040 divided by
the product of its unique prime factors
pause the video right now if you'd like
to give it a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
[Music]
to solve this problem we need to find
the prime factorization of 5040. since
it's an even number it's divisible by 2.
since 2520 is an even number we can
divide by 2 again
and then 1260 is an even number so we
divide by 2 again
630 is also even so we divide by 2 again
315 is odd so we can't divide by 2 any
more times now the digits of 315 are 3 1
and 5.
if we add them together we get 9. so 315
will be divisible by 9.
so it will be divisible by 3 and it'll
be divisible by 3 again
now 35 is equal to 5 times 7.
this is the prime factorization of 5040.
we need the quotient of this with its
unique prime factors
the unique prime factors are two three
five and seven
we divide both sides by two three five
and seven and we end up with the
quotient of 5040 by its unique prime
factors
the result will be 2 cubed times 3 and
that's equal to 24 and that's our answer
it took me a couple of minutes to do
this calculation and to be sure that i
got the correct answer but my solved
this question in only seconds
congratulations again
and who knows with all the smart viewers
unmind your decisions maybe the winner
of next year's math counts competition
is watching this video right now
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you